quelle belle histoire que celle racontée
par ce documentaire nous littéralement
lumière en arabe réalisé par Stéphanie
Lebrun et Shazam Haddad de cette chorale
lyrique dont les tours de chant nous
donne aussi malheureusement avoir l'état
dramatique dans lequel se trouve
désormais leur pays de quoi s'interroger
sur les chemins possibles pour une
reconstruction en Syrie avec toujours à
sa tête Bachar el-Assad c'est ce que
nous allons faire à présent avec notre
invités présents sur ce plateau de débat
doc Agnès Levallois tout d'abord
bienvenue vous êtes politologue
spécialiste du monde arabe maîtresse de
recherche à la Fondation pour la
recherche stratégique et aussi
vice-présidente de l'Institut de
recherche et d'études Méditerranée
moyenne Orient George wal Bruno est
également avec nous bienvenue à vous et
vous êtes gore porteurs pour le
quotidien le figarose spécialiste du
Moyen-Orient votre dernier livre
s'intitule le déclassement français
Élisée Quai d'Orsay DGSE les secrets
d'une guerre d'influence stratégique un
ouvrage coécrit avec votre compère
Christian Chesneau de France Inter et
publié chez Michel Lafont et puis enfin
avec nous Aymeric eluin bienvenue à vous
vous êtes responsable du plaidoyer armes
et conflit au sein d'amnistie
International France on va commencer si
vous le voulez bien après ce formidable
documentaire c'est vrai qu'il nous donne
une note d'espoir dans un environnement
particulièrement dramatique on va y
revenir bien entendu tous les trois on
va commencer par resituer bien sûr la
Syrie avec notamment ces pays voisins la
Jordanie Israël ça c'est pour le sud et
le sud-ouest du pays le Liban évidemment
à l'ouest la Turquie au nord avec une
frontière très importante plus de 900 km
de frontières on y reviendra sans doute
à l'occasion de notre échange et puis du
côté Est et sud-est et bien l'Irak pays
frontaliers avec la Syrie bien
évidemment ensuite une seconde carte
celle-ci concerne la Syrie elle-même
avec 70% du territoire qui figure sur
cette carte en rouge qui est contrôlé
par les forces de Bachar el-Assad et ses
alliés en jaune vous pouvez voir les
forces Kurdes et alliées situées au
nord-est du pays quelques groupes
rebelles en vert l'État islamique qui
conserve visiblement une poche de
présence dans une zone désertique que
vous voyez sur cette carte figuré en
noir et puis enfin l'armée turque et
milice islamiste qui se situe au nord du
pays justement à cette frontière Turco
syrienne que vous voyez apparaître sur
cette carte en mauve première question
elle peut surprendre Agnès Levallois
mais après avoir vu cette carte on ne
peut que vous la poser est-ce que la
bière la guerre pardon est bien terminée
en Syrie aujourd'hui non la guerre n'est
absolument pas terminée aujourd'hui en
Syrie pas cher al-Assad tente de
démontrer que la guerre est terminée
parce qu'il contrôle à nouveau une
partie du territoire vous l'avez dit
on parle de 65 à 70% du territoire
contrôlé par celui-ci alors qu'à un
moment il n'en contrôlait plus que 35%.
donc il y a évidemment il a reconquis
enfin surtout ces alliés l'ont aidé à
reconquérir quand je parle de ses alliés
ce sont les Russes et les Iraniens et
quelques milices qui participent à cette
reconquête mais on voit bien sur cette
carte que la situation est loin d'être
stabilisée que celui-ci effectivement
contrôle Damas Alep maintenant mais que
dépend entier continuent à lui échapper
et que même s'il y a eu moins de combats
depuis le covid puisqu'il y avait une
trêve qui avait été demandée par l'ONU à
l'époque puisque il y avait déjà
suffisamment de défis à relever pour la
population qui était de combattre ce
virus donc qui est moins de combat mais
on sait que les combats ont repris
puisque l'objectif de Bachar el-Assad
c'est de venir à bout en particulier de
ce qu'on appelle l'enclave de Idlib qui
est cette zone au nord-ouest du pays qui
est tenu laquelle un certain nombre de
rebelles et de groupes islamistes armés
ont été lorsqu'ils ont quitté les autres
zones sous la force de la reprise du
territoire par les forces de vassades à
comparer par les Russes et les Iraniens
et donc l'objectif de Assad c'est
vraiment de réduire ce qu'il appelle
cette poche c'est un peu compliqué ce
qu'il y a quand même au moins 3 millions
de personnes donc on peut pas venir à
bout de cette façon-là mais des
bombardements continuent à atteindre
cette zone sans parler de la zone qui
elle est contrôlée par les Kurdes que le
régime aimerait bien le régime aimerait
bien reprendre le contrôle complètement
même s'il y a des négociations entre
Damas et une partie des Kurdes mais tout
ça pour dire que cette situation est
loin d'être stabilisée et que je ne
pense qu'en aucun cas on peut parler de
la fin de la guerre en Syrie mais ma vie
Georges Bruno ou pas
alors moi je dirais que depuis 2017
cette situation est à peu près
stabilisée non la guerre pour la chute
de Bachar el-Assad est terminé parce que
on voit mal comment ces opposants
aujourd'hui qui ont été comme Agnès l'a
dit réduit quand même pourraient
renverser Bachar Elsa ce qui était leur
but depuis 2011 en revanche comme ça a
été dit effectivement la guerre pour
Bachar el-Assad pour recouvrer
l'intégralité du territoire elle n'est
pas terminée c'est bien la raison pour
laquelle il l'a continue simplement il y
a ces deux poches qu'on a vu en
particulier au nord-ouest là la zone
d'Idleb qui est toujours je dirais
incandescente avec effectivement c'est
là aussi où les les effets du
tremblement de terre sont les plus
importants les plus dramatiques en Syrie
cette poche qui est toujours donc au mas
de rebelle djihadiste ou islamiste
contrôler à distance par la Turquie et
qui pose un problème et puis et comme ça
a été dit aussi le Nord kurde simplement
je pense qu'on est rentré dans une
nouvelle phase du conflit qui est un
conflit effectivement qui continue mais
dans une phase je dirais presque à la
fois de de pré reconstruction parce
qu'il y a pas eu on en reparlera de
reconstruction physique matérielle il y
a des pays qui sont et puis d'une phase
de recomposition avec à la fois la
personnalité d'Assad qui a été ou qui
est en train d'être réintégré par les
pays de la région dans leur majorité y
compris la Turquie et et donc pour faire
en sorte que et bien cette poche ditleb
qui est l'abscède fixation des derniers
combats en gros et bien une issue soit
trouvée et là ça demande la
participation et de la Turquie bien sûr
qui contrôle en sous-main cette poche
dit de l'aide la Russie également et
l'Iran et c'est ce vers quoi je pense on
va s'acheminer prochainement donc plus
que de la construction je dirais
matériel de la Syrie qu'il y en a
grandement besoin on en reparlera cette
recomposition un petit peu
dont il faut parler parce que je crois
que ça sera le prochain événement majeur
de la Syrie dans les dans les prochains
mois les dernières questions que je pose
peut-être là à l'un ou l'autre avant de
d'en venir à vous la question kurde là
on est au nord nord-est du pays
concernant le les Kurdes est-ce que ça
en passera par une négociation est-ce
que la revendication d'autonomie venant
des Kurdes à des chances d'aboutir
auprès du pouvoir de Bachar el-Assad où
est-ce que là aussi il faudra peut-être
pour bacharger la salle en passer par
une une reconquête armée alors je pense
que la reconquête armée est impossible
aujourd'hui l'armée de Bachar el-Assad
n'a absolument pas les moyens de lancer
une opération d'envergure pour reprendre
ce territoire aujourd'hui cette armée
qui a quand même la guerre a commencé il
y a enfin le conflit en Syrie a commencé
il y a 12 ans et donc c'est une armée
qui est complètement un exemple avec une
difficulté à recruter puisque les jeunes
syriens majoritairement sont partis ou
tentent encore de partir pour ne pas
faire leur semitère et donc ne pas
participer à des opérations de la sorte
donc militairement il n'a pas les moyens
de faire ce genre d'opération même s'il
est aidé grandement par les Russes les
Iraniens on l'a déjà dit donc il y a des
négociations qui est qui se déroulent
entre Bachar el-Assad et les Kurdes ou
dans un premier temps Bachar al-Assad
accepte une certaine autonomie des cures
dont il s'est qualitinéluctable mais
comme on le sait aussi la parole de
Bachar el-Assad n'a aucune valeur donc
il peut promettre aujourd'hui ou tenter
de promettre une certaine autonomie mais
qui par la suite ne sera pas forcément
respecté
aujourd'hui on peut dire les choses
comme ça oui surtout ce qu'il faut
ajouter c'est que l'avenir des Kurdes
dépenses surtout des négociations qui
ont commencé et qui vont probablement se
prolonger entre turcs et syriens sous
les gîtes de la Russie et probablement
de l'Iran et c'est là c'est là où on
pourrait assister à inversement parce
que dans la mesure où il y a un accord
entre turc et syriens ça va remettre je
dirais le la cartographie du reliquat de
guerre qui est la situation actuelle
complètement ça va complètement changer
cette cartographie parce que lorsqu'il y
aura cet accord s'il y en a c'est pas
sûr mais on peut penser que il pourra y
en avoir un dans les mois qui viennent
et bien la poche dit de l'herbe au
nord-ouest
reviendra vraisemblablement sous le
giron si rien que les djihadistes qui
sont là partiront en Turquie en
Afghanistan et ailleurs certains ont
Ukraine comme c'est déjà le cas et que
nos alliés kurdes en revanche
risqueraient de retomber dans le giron
damassen et qui serait effectivement
sacrifié ce qui pose
un problème pour nous qui sont nos
alliés on a quelques efforts spéciales
qui sont là-bas et surtout pour les
Américains qui sont présents quid de la
présence américaine dans le cadre de
cette de ce remodlement qui n'est pas
encore d'actualité mais dont on parle et
on va en parler probablement tout à
l'heure quand on abordera l'aspect
géopolitique notamment avec les pays
absolument du Golfe Aymeric éluin est-ce
que on parle d'un pays en guerre du côté
d'Amnesty International est-ce que le
diagnostic est celui-là concernant
l'état humanitaire l'état politique de
ce pays moi je crois que je rejoins ce
qui était dit ici sur ce plateau le
conflit tel qu'on l'a connu en 2013
n'est plus mais le conflit s'est arrêté
le confine c'est pas achevé aujourd'hui
on parle encore de tactique de guerre
qui sont utilisés pour viser
délibérément des civils pour viser
délibérément des infrastructures civiles
il y a peu de temps fin janvier nous
nous sortions un comité de paix pardon
pour dénoncer le blocus mis en place par
le régime syrien sur certaines zones de
la ville d'Alep pour empêcher et
cantonner donc les Kurdes de cette zone
et qui n'avaient du coup accès aucune
aide humanitaire qui n'avait pas accès à
une aide médicale des soins et les
transports de farine même étaient
bloqués le boulanger ne pouvait même
plus travailler dans la zone les gens
étaient réduits à brûler parce que
l'hiver dans la zone était extrêmement
fort des objets en plastique avec les
conséquences que l'on connaît donc la
façon de faire la guerre n'a pas changé
parce que la guerre a continué dans
certaines zones du pays le pays on l'a
dit
le régime de Bachir al-Assad en contrôle
que 70% le reste du pays est soumis
attention ce n'est pas un pays
aujourd'hui qui est qui est sûr c'est un
pays où les violences ne cessent de
continuer que ce soit de la part de
groupe armés dit terroristes relevant de
la mouvance de l'État islamiste etc donc
et le régime syrien avec l'aide des
Russes n'a pas arrêté de commettre des
atrocités donc et la technique des
blocus que nous avons dénoncé encore il
y a quelques semaines concernant ces
zones de du nord de la ville d'Alep ne
sont pas nous ces techniques ne sont pas
nouvelles ce sont des techniques
consistant à sier des villes pour les
faire rendre et faire rendre gorges de
la population pour que la population
affamée dit stop libérez nous donc je
crois qu'il faut garder en tête que
c'est un pays qui est soumis encore
aujourd'hui à une violence sans nom
clairement avec un non respect du droit
international humanitaire qui est majeur
et je rappelle que quand on appuie comme
technique de guerre le blocus d'une
ville c'est contraire au droit
international la principale les
principales obligations en tant que
conflit c'est de permettre à cheminement
de la l'humanitaire pour permettre aux
populations de subvenir à leurs besoins
de première nécessité et là il faut
empêcher par les fourches coding du
pouvoir de dirigé par Bachar el-Assad il
y a pas d'autres moyens d'acheminer des
aides humanité au jour quand vous avez
le régime syrien le contrôle une bonne
partie du territoire et là aujourd'hui
encore nous sortons un communiqué de
presse pour dénoncer la façon dont le
régime syrien mais aussi à certains
groupes de position dans le nord de la
Syrie bloque la cheminement de l'aide
humanitaire ce qui est dramatique par
ailleurs parce que quand vous bloquez la
cheminement de fioul qui est nécessaire
pour faire fonctionner les machines et
toute la technique la technique des
sauveteurs vous retardez
donc c'est absolument criminel ce qui
est en train de se passer l'attitude à
la fois du régime syrien et des groupes
de position notamment sous influenceurs
que dans le nord de la Syrie qui empêche
cette aide notamment kurde d'aller
rejoindre le nord de la ville d'Alep ou
le gouvernorat enfin le nord du
gouvernement du gouverneur pardonale et
criminels il faut laisser l'acheminement
de l'allumette se faire librement alors
en étant déjà à réfléchir à la
reconstruction diplomatique peut-être on
va y venir peut-être George malbruno le
fait que Bachar el-Assad a été réélu
pour la quatrième fois la tête de son
pays
c'était en mai 2021 dans des conditions
très particulières puisque tous les
exilés n'ont pas pu voter toutes les
personnes déplacées à l'intérieur du
pays et ça représente tout de même
plusieurs millions de personnes
également n'ont pas pu voter
95,1% c'est le score réalisé pour cette
réélection de Bachar el-Assad est-ce
qu'il est encore et toujours
incontournable si on veut commencer à
parler de reconstruction aujourd'hui en
Syrie alors qu'il est il est mieux il
est mis au banc des sociétés
démocratiques occidentales d'ailleurs au
même titre que ces alliés aujourd'hui la
Russie et l'Iran vous avez cité bien
entendu tout à l'heure moi je crois que
de parler de reconstruction est bien
trop prématuré la situation ne se prête
absolument pas à une quelconque
reconstruction alors que le pays on
vient de le dire est encore complètement
situation de guerre donc la
reconstruction n'a pas de sens la
réélection de Bachar el-Assad que vous
avez évoqué évidemment c'est passé dans
des conditions si ça n'était pas aussi
dramatique on pourrait dire ubuesque
puisque plus de la moitié de la
population de toute façon on n'a pas pu
voter donc tout ça ne correspond à rien
la réalité c'est effectivement il est au
pouvoir il fallait rester il est
toujours à Damas avec très peu de
pouvoir entre les mains quand même
puisque si les Russes et les Iraniens se
retiraient demain matin je pense qu'il
aurait les plus grandes difficultés à se
maintenir donc il est là mais parce
qu'il est soutenu et à bout de bras par
les Russes et les Iraniens maintenant
effectivement il y a de plus en plus une
tentative ou une volonté de certains
pays de la région à renouer avec
celui-ci ou en tous les cas à sortir de
l'ostracisme dans lequel il était parce
que l'inquiétude des pays qui en
particulier ont repris langue avec le
régime d'Assad et je pense aux Émirats
arabes unis veulent à travers la contrer
l'influence iranienne qui existe dans ce
pays et donc l'objectif des émirats
c'est de en étant Damas en rouvrant
l'ambassade c'est de savoir ce qui se
passe dans le pays et de pouvoir contrer
cette influence iranienne qui inquiète
fortement les pieds du golf donc oui il
y a une tendance de la part de certains
pays à anormaliser pour l'instant ça
reste pas marginal puisqu'on voit qu'il
y a un vrai mouvement qui a été lancé
mais avec des résultats finalement à
quoi ça rime parce que je pense qu'il va
falloir se poser la question tout à
l'heure dans ce débat qu'est-ce que ça
veut dire de normaliser normaliser
pourquoi et ça je pense qu'on est on y
reviendra ce que ça me paraît essentiel
comme ça
le boulot à cette question parce que
et la reconstruction de notre point de
vue européen c'est beaucoup trop tôt
parce que Bachar el-Assad est encore là
il est infréquentable
pour nous voilà en revanche si on se
place du point de vue jordanien irakien
et myrien
algérien tunisien libanais probablement
turc
Bachar el-Assad est là on l'aime pas
mais il est là il sera là demain et donc
il faut il faut comme ça toujours été le
cas avec la série il faut pouvoir
contrôler la capacité de nuisance de la
Syrie jadis c'était par un double jeu
vis-à-vis du terrorisme on laissait
passer des djihadistes on en arrêt de
terre on a renvoyait en France on les
laissait passer etc aujourd'hui la
capacité de nuisance est plus tellement
celle-là quoi que il y a quand même
encore de nombreux djihadistes étrangers
dont au moins 130 français dans la poche
dead donc qu'est-ce qu'on en fait demain
et mais ces choses aussi la capacité de
nuisance vient par exemple la production
de drogue du captagone qui est devenu
qui est devenu la principale source de
revenus du régime syrien donc ces
pays-là autour se disent bon il faut on
est victime la Jordanie est victime de
ce trafic de captagone qui fait que la
société jordanienne est affectée grand
grandement les pays du Golfe également
et puis comme tu l'as dit
Hassan on l'aime pas les arabes on
l'aime pas les Saoudiens ne l'aiment pas
les émiriens probablement pas etc mais
il est là et ce qu'on veut c'est essayer
de détacher la Syrie de l'Iran qui a
toujours été historiquement l'Allier la
Syrie est un pays arabe l'Iran est un
pays qui n'est pas arabe pour le golf
pour l'Arabie en particulier Damas entre
les mains des Iraniens c'était une
aberration et donc après moult réflexion
s'est dit bah on a tout fermé en 2012
les ambassades on a laissé à ça de face
à ses ennemis à ses amis pardon l'Iran
et la Russie on est parti aujourd'hui on
a perdu à ça des toujours là et donc
profitons justement du levier de la
reconstruction qui a l'argent dans la
région c'est le golf et dire on veut
bien ni la Russie nelliran ne l'ont ni
la Russie ni l'Iran Delon et de le
donneront pas mais en revanche les
Émirats peuvent dire alors on en parlera
des sanctions qui affectent la Syrie
peuvent dire à Hassan et c'est ce qui se
dit je pense
on revient on te réintègre peut-être
probablement demain ou après-demain dans
la Ligue arabe simplement écarte l'Iran
au moins militairement on demande pas de
rompre diplomatiquement avec l'Iran mais
fait en sorte que la Syrie ne soit plus
un état vassal de l'Iran et donc c'est
ça l'enjeu et donc à ça fait un pas en
avant un pas en arrière et effectivement
et c'est là toute la toute la comment
dirais-je la mécanique qui va se jouer
dans ces et c'est ce qui explique que
les pays arabes se disent il faut la
série elle est incontournables qu'on
aime ou on n'aime pas ça et les
incontournables essayons de faire en
sorte qu'elle se détache au moins de
l'Iran et qu'elle arrête de nous inonder
de capitagone et vous parler de la Ligue
arabe parce que la prochaine réunion de
la Ligue arabe aura lieu en Arabie
Saoudite qui va prendre la présidence
de réintégrer ou pas parce que la série
au sein de la Ligue 1 des partisans et
des non partisans de cette non partisans
et le Maroc a plus beaucoup de non
partisans vous lui rajoutez quelque
chose et ensuite je vais vous
[Musique]
c'est une approche qui est extrêmement
intéressante de parler de reconstruction
et de nouveaux départs qui se dit
beaucoup c'est que c'est pas un problème
humanitaire aujourd'hui mais c'est un
problème politique alors quand on voit
l'état humanitaire de ce pays on s'est
dit que ça risque d'être
pas c'est pas seulement humanitaire
parce que vous embête ce pays est
exemple ce pays au-delà des questions de
trafic de drogue cap d'Agon d'influence
géopolitique et le plus grand perdant de
cette guerre c'est la population civile
vous avez 11 millions de personnes qui
qui ont fui leur foyer 6 millions qui
sont des déplacés internes un peu plus
et plus de 5 millions qui ont quitté
leur pays qui sont réfugiés c'est un
pays dont le régime a utilisé une arme
de solution massive l'arme chimique le
chlore le sarin neurotoxique suffocant
pour l'utiliser contre sa population
civile c'est un pays qui a utilisé des
armes sous-munitions interdites par le
droit international les mêmes qui sont
utilisés aujourd'hui à Carson en Ukraine
des armes à soumission russe pour
frapper sa population civile c'est un
pays qui a mis au point les barils
explosif pour venir décimer des
quartiers entiers de ville c'est des
populations qui ont fait l'objet de
campagne de disparition forcée
souvenez-vous de la prison de saïdana
nous n'avions sortis un rapport en 2017
où on expliquait que de 2011 à 2015 vous
avez 13000 personnes à peu près environ
qui ont été pendus c'est colossal
rappelons-nous de raka la prise de RACA
les tas islamiques un officiel américain
comme nous le disions dans un rapport se
réjouissait d'avoir tiré 30000 coups
d'artillerie pour en venir à bout de
l'État islamique sur quatre mois c'est à
dire 6 coups par minute la ville de
Rakan ressemble à plus rien aujourd'hui
c'est un désert de béton c'est des
débris d'acier entre mes lèvres le béton
donc aujourd'hui ce pays est exemple ne
ressemble plus à rien il est défiguré
donc pareil de reconstruction c'est
d'abord aussi parler de justice et que
fait-on pour ces populations syriennes
qui ont vécu l'horreur et le cercle de
l'enfer l'a dit un des témoins que nous
avons interviewé jusqu'au bout vous me
dites pas de reconstruction aujourd'hui
pas de reconstruction parce que les
principaux
ne peuvent pas mettre la trésorerie
nécessaire on l'a évoqué Russie Iran
ou alors pas de reconstruction parce que
tant que les démocraties occidentales
qui ont mis Bachar à la salle et avec
sans doute raison sur le critère
démocratique au bon des sociétés
aujourd'hui
ne souhaite pas être construction ils ne
peuvent peut-être pas rentrer en contact
directement avec ceux qui pourraient
mettre en oeuvre cette reconstruction en
fait la question qui se pose c'est que
aujourd'hui quand on entend dire il faut
normaliser avec Bachar el-Assad
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire normaliser
pour faire quoi on ne peut pas
normaliser avec un régime comme le
régime syrien pour toutes les raisons
qui viennent d'être évoquées parce que
c'est un régime et souvenez-vous de
Bachar el-Assad qui disait face caméra
que son pays n'avait jamais utilisé
alors que tous les rapports le démontre
c'est un régime avec lequel on ne peut
pas parler parce qu'il ne pas ils
passent son temps à mentir et à dire
tout et n'importe quoi donc normaliser
si ça permettait d'apporter une certaine
stabilité politique pour apporter des
solutions à la population syrienne qui
souffre le martyre depuis 12 ans oui
bien sûr il faudrait normaliser demain
matin sauf que elles ont débloqué des
fonds avec pour venir en aide au
réfugiés notamment un les pays
occidentaux bien sûr parce que l'idée
aujourd'hui c'est de apporter une aide
humanitaire à la population syrienne qui
s'ouvre en particulier depuis le
tremblement de terre alors que Bachar
el-Assad instrumentalise actuellement
c'était l'humanitaire en disant tout
doit passer par Damas parce que je suis
le chef et que c'est moi qui vais
distribuer sauf qu'on sait très bien que
Assad ne va pas distribuer de l'aide
humanitaire dans la fameuse zone de
idhib dont on a parlé parce que c'est la
zone qu'il veut éradiquer et donc il est
au contraire passez-moi expression ravi
de ce qui se passe dans la zone de Easy
qui permet d'éliminer des Syriens dont
il ne veut plus parce que pour reprendre
son expression aujourd'hui il a la
société plus saine parce que elle a été
éliminée de ses opposants on est dans ce
type de rhétorique de la part de ce
régime Bachar el-Assad a dit que c'était
très bien que la moitié de sa population
soit partie parce qu'il avait matin une
société qui était plus homogène donc on
est à ce degré je vais dire d'inhumanité
et donc normaliser avec ce régime pour
faire quoi pour obtenir quoi on ne à mon
avis on ne peut rien obtenir de ce
régime parce que c'est un régime qui est
complètement dans la logique que il faut
écraser tous ceux qui ne partagent pas
ses idées et donc à partir de là à mon
avis on n'a rien à gagner à une
normalité c'est une négociation qui
permet d'apporter quelque chose ce
régime va vous dire droit dans les yeux
oui la duanitaire je la prends et je
vais la distribue il va pas la
distribuer c'est au contraire
l'association gérée par sa femme qui va
en manger les trois quarts comme ça a
été dit dans un rapport de l'ONU
récemment c'est ça la réalité de ce
régime alors si on normalise pas je vais
quand même rappeler c'est quelques
chiffres une restre trois minutes en
2018 l'envoyé spécial des Nations Unies
pour la Syrie avait chiffré à 250
milliards de dollars soit plus de 4 fois
le produit brut intérieur de la Syrie
avant le déclenchement de la guerre le
montant de la facture pour la
reconstruction cette facture
avoisinerait même à présent 400
milliards de dollars et ça c'est selon
les estimations des autorités russes et
syriennes sur normalisent pas d'une
manière ou d'une autre comment peut-on
espérer débloquer les sommes dont on
parle qui sont colossales pour une
reconstruction future de la Syrie des
freins principaux à la reconstruction ce
sont les sanctions notamment américaines
qui sont apogées qui perdurent
effectivement tant qu'il y aura pas de
transition etc donc effectivement même
les États comme les Émirats arabes unis
qui ont établi quasiment un pont aérien
avec Damas ce qui est humanitaire très
bien en dehors de ça pour la
reconstruction c'est pas c'est pas
permis donc effectivement il y a cette
ce que Agnès dit a tout à fait vrai
[Musique]
où il était question en parlant du
régime de bachar-assad de la pire
entreprise criminelle qui est jamais été
menée depuis la Seconde Guerre mondiale
je répète la pire entreprise criminelle
c'est pas des mots que l'on jette comme
ça à la légère alors Emmanuel Macron
peut-être pense d'une autre façon
cette normalisation ne pourra pas
s'accompagner sans qu'il y ait de
justice qui soit mis en place que ce
soit au niveau national ou au niveau
international aujourd'hui il y a
peut-être des sanctions américaines mais
il y en a aussi des sanctions
européennes et si ces sanctions existent
c'est aussi parce que les Nations Unies
n'ont pas pu en adopter sinon elles en
ont adopté les Russes se sont opposés à
l'adoption il y a eu 15 vétos 15 véto
russe et chinois contre des résolutions
des Nations Unies visant à protéger les
populations civiles donc les
responsabilités elles sont partagées et
peut-être que certains pays veulent
aller vers une forme de normalisation
notamment dans la région de pays arabes
un certain nombre de pays arabes
l'évolution de la dynamique régionale ne
fera jamais l'économie d'un mouvement en
faveur d'une justice pour cette
population civile parce que ces
populations civile aujourd'hui qui
souffrent dans sa chair c'est celle qui
demain permettra de conduire le pays
donc si on les laisse sur le bord de la
route ces gens là seront un jour en
danger à nouveau donc il faut s'en
occuper c'est terminé malheureusement on
serait resté bien plus longtemps avec
vous trois pour parler de cette des
pistes de reconstruction possible en
Syrie le sujet de ce débat doc
aujourd'hui après ce formidable
documentaire qui était lourd lumière en
arabe c'était la seule petite note
d'espoir peut-être de cette émission
aujourd'hui mais elle est là cette note
d'espoir malgré tout vos réactions
hashtag débat doc sur Twitter merci à
Selma Sally qui comme à l'accoutumée m'a
aidé à préparer cette émission et je
vous donne rendez-vous bien entendu pour
un prochain débat doc et ça sera bien
sûr avec son documentaire et son débat à
bientôt
[Musique]